hörst du dich laut und klar schluss klar
eindruck ich bin aufgeflogen jeweils
mich rausholen unterwegs reingehen sich
anschauen popcorn essen und danach
denken ja jetzt könnte man gerade noch
mal reingehen und sich die sause von
vorne schauen
unser agent ethan hunt hat es diesmal
mit einer ganz besonders widerwärtigen
art von bösewichten zu tun es sind
nämlich bösewichte die so tun als
wollten sie der welt etwas sehr gutes
tun indem sie schreckliches unglück an
gerichten und zwar mit hilfe von pocken
und pluto worden und genau für solche
szenarien wurde das heft des mfs trier
halloween allen eine bande männer mit
gummimasken die süßes oder saures
spielen und hätte er in berlin das
plutonium sichergestellt werden wir
diese unterhaltung jetzt nicht führen
und sein team wäre tot er das wären sie
so läuft dieser job also muss sagen die
story ist wie immer natürlich schon
reich seinen haaren herbeigezogen man
darf das jetzt auch nicht alles so
furchtbar auf die goldwaage legen ob das
in sich so konzise ist aber mir
persönlich ist bei dieser art von film
das komplett egal ich will jemanden
sehen der an sich zum tode rennt um die
welt zu retten
und das ganze in schön choreografierten
action szenen wie man sich gerne
anschaut wo man hinterher ausgeht und
denkt das waren erst mal so ein zwei
drei stunden wo ich mich einfach richtig
entspannen konnte und zugeschaut habe
weder einen einfachen lösungen große
probleme auf die reihe bekommt wie geht
es ihm
weißt du bist immer noch ganz gehalten
tom cruise macht alles was er als ethan
hunt tun sollte er hängt sich an einen
helikopter er rennt von explosionen weg
er stürzt sich in schluchten er krallt
sich an häuserwände wohl einfach
geradeaus gerade bei den dreharbeiten
hat er sich einen knöchel gebrochen und
diese szene mit dem gebrochenen knöchel
das ist die also in london über ein
häuser dach rennt dann über eine
häuserschlucht hinweg springt und sich
an der gegenüber liegenden straßenseite
festkrallt die ist auch mit dem film und
er rennt danach sogar weiter das ist
doch was heldentum
worauf wartest du dennoch ich springe
hier aus dem fenster es ist glaube ich
das besondere an mission impossible dass
tom cruise wirklich wert darauf legt
dass die stunts handgemacht sind das ist
also viel selbst erlebt und mit echter
körperliche qual verbunden und das sieht
man der sache an das ist jetzt nicht
alles im computer generiert und wirkt
dadurch auch sehr authentisch
[Musik]
auf jeden fall muss man die anderen
teile nicht gesehen haben um spaß an
diesen film zu haben
man muss auch nicht unbedingt die story
verstehen um spaß an diesem film zu
haben
es ist einfach eine große action sause
die sehr toll choreografiert ist und
einfach spaß macht und auch ein
positives bild von einem helden zeichnet
dem das schicksal des einzelnen nicht
egal ist wenn es darum geht das große
ganze zu wecken